right when blue state governors justify
their continuing stay at home orders
even with Cova death in their state's
relatively low they invariably
regurgitate the same justification we're
gonna do the right thing not judged by
politics not judged by protests but by
science not to be a broken record but
we're looking at data we have to make
the best informed decisions based on
data and science with the information we
have well that sounds good but are they
actually listening to the science and is
the science even settled well last month
before governors began locking down
their state's prominent Stanford
epidemiologist John ayan Edie's may
depression observation he said in the
absence of data
prepare for the worst reasoning leads to
extreme measures of social distancing in
lockdowns unfortunately we don't know if
these measures work well for raising
this inconvenient truth or even
questioning the orthodoxy the good
professor became an instant pariah in
the medical establishment circles now
others just ignored him hoping it go
away but new data seems to support
skepticism of the effectiveness of
social distancing now wouldn't you know
that our dear friends over at Facebook
actually created their own database that
measures and tracks social distancing in
every US state they use two different
metrics and they're examined the first
is called relative mobility change which
is how often someone travels outside his
or her area home area the second is the
stay-put percentage or the percentage of
people who stayed in their homes for the
day now if you look closely and off you
can on the graphic on TV but we see that
the states with the largest drops in
quote relative mobility and the largest
increases in their stay put percentage
are also the states with the most
confirmed kovat cases and deaths now New
Yorkers in New Jerseyans were
understandably terrified about this
virus and took the stay at home home
orders quite seriously but nevertheless
the virus continued to spread
would it have been worse without the
social distancing maybe do we know that
for certain
no although the Facebook mapping isn't
dispositive it merely confirms or
reconfirms I should say what we need to
ask and the questions we need answered
about the true efficacy of these social
mitigation measures
now remember experts don't like to admit
they're wrong
do they after all they're supposed to be
smarter than the rest of us I all this
stuff well then there's the other new
article of Kovac faith masks now like
most Americans weeks ago I began wearing
a mask while grocery shopping and I've
talked about this before but I have been
a notorious germaphobe for decades and
it's so bad that my fellow airline
passengers they used to look at me
really weirdly when I carried out my
ritual disinfecting you know regimen
that I did with the sprays and wiping
down
well now everybody's a germaphobe right
well and in March I thought if Master
what it takes to get Americans back to
business sooner and I assumed it'd be
temporary then fine what's the big deal
but then I started to see people
fiddling with their masks touching their
faces readjusting the masks even shaming
others for not wearing masks when you're
outdoors and exercising like running
past someone ten feet away you're not
wearing a mask
well I started to ask questions so do
these masks a lot of them are homemade
really slow the spread of Kovach it
seems like five minutes ago we were told
they weren't necessary at all and now
there is commonplace of sweat pants
numerous airlines are as of today
requiring them of both crew and
passengers and they're even becoming
well masks are becoming kind of fashion
accessories but since we're supposed to
be guided by actual facts what does the
science actually say about masks I'm not
talking about the n95 masks which work
pretty well and they're you know in the
clinical that in the hospital setting
but I'm talking about the homemade ones
they're kind of fun to make we've made
some of them here well may cheer of
Epidemiology at the Colorado School of
Public Health says the homemade cotton
masks
only stop about two percent of the
airflow coming in two percent and those
surgical blue masks that you see all
around and people throw them away
they're in the gutters now they're like
a ecological hazard while they're good
in the again medical setting operating
room in and out of medical procedures
they aren't very effective out in public
to told LiveScience she said these masks
don't seal against the face about 70
percent of the outside air moves through
the mask
and about 30 percent travels around the
sides in other words the masks don't
catch the droplets now if experts
advising our government officials want
the rest of us to take them seriously
then their recommendations have to be
reasonable and well-founded and it would
be nice if they were occasionally
consistent if they're not you know that
no one's gonna listen and if and if
they're not held accountable for being
wrong then I don't know where that
leaves us I'm telling you be prepared
though as all this plays out for more
petty power grabs and I'm talking about
of the sort we've seen from Michigan
Governor Gretchen Whitmer today anti
shutdown protesters converged on the
State Capitol there presumably state
reps listened and they adjourned the
Republicans without extending the state
of emergency in Michigan will see what
governor Whitmer does now apparently
she's just yawning Americans though were
smart and now they're in
self-preservation mode and they're
beginning to ask more questions